is there advice
outside of love that you can give to
young people
you were a million years ago a professor
is there advice you can give to young
people high schoolers college students
about career about life yeah but it's
not
they're not going to like it because
it's not easy to operationalize so and
this was a problem when i was a college
professor too people would ask me
what they should do should they go to
graduate school i had almost nothing
useful to say
because the job market and the market of
you know pre-job training and all of
that these things are
all so distorted
and corrupt that i didn't want to point
anybody to anything
right because it's all broken and i
would tell them that
but i would say that results in a kind
of uh
meta-level advice that i do think is
useful
you don't know what's coming you don't
know where the opportunities will be
you should invest in tools rather than
knowledge
right to the extent that you can do
things you can repurpose that
no matter what the future brings to the
extent that you know
if you as a robot guy right you've got
the skills of a robot guy
now if civilization failed and the stuff
of robot building
disappeared with it you'd still have the
mind of a robot guy and the mind of a
robot guy can retool around all kinds of
things whether you're
you know forced to work with you know
you know fibers that are made into ropes
right
your mechanical mind would be useful in
all kinds of places so
invest in tools like that that can be
easily repurposed
and invest in combinations of tools
right if civilization keeps
limping along you're going to be up
against all sorts of people who have
studied
the things that you studied right if you
think hey computer programming is really
really cool
and you pick up computer programming
guess what you just entered a large
group of people who have that skill and
many of them will be better than you
almost certainly on the other hand if
you
combine that with something else that's
very rarely combined with it
if you have i don't know if it's
carpentry
and computer programming if you take
combinations of things
that are even if they're both common but
they're not commonly found together
and those combinations create a rarefied
space
where you inhabit it and even if the
things don't even really touch
but nonetheless they create a mind in
which the two things are live and you
can move back and forth between them
and you know step out of your own
perspective by moving from one to the
other
that will increase what you can see and
the quality of your tools
and so anyway that isn't useful advice
it doesn't tell you whether you should
go to graduate school
or not but it does tell you the one
thing we can say
for certain about the future is that
it's uncertain and so prepare for it
and like you said there's cool things to
be discovered in the intersection of
uh fields and ideas and i would
look at grad school that way actually if
you do go
or i see
i mean this is such a like every course
in grad school
undergrad too was like this little
journey
that you're on that explores a
particular field
and it's not immediately obvious how
useful it is
but it allows you to to discover
intersections between that thing and
some other thing
so you you're bringing to the table this
these pieces of knowledge some of which
when intersected might
create a niche that's completely novel
unique and will bring you joy
i have that i mean i took a huge number
of courses in uh theoretical computer
science
most of them seem useless but they
totally change the way i see the world
uh in ways that are i'm not prepared or
it's a little bit difficult to kind of
make
explicit but
taken together they've allowed me to see
for example the world of robotics
totally different
and different from many of my colleagues
and friends and so on and i think
that it's a good way to see if you go to
grad school as um
as a opportunity to explore
intersections of fields
even if the individual fields seem
useless yeah
and useless doesn't mean useless right
useless means not directly applicable
a good useless course can be the best
one you ever took
um yeah i took uh james joyce a course
on james joyce and that
was truly useless well i took uh
i took immunobiology in the medical
school when i was at penn
as uh i guess i would have been a
freshman or a sophomore i wasn't
supposed to be in this class
it blew my goddamn mind and it still
does
right i mean we had this i don't even
know who it was but
we had this great professor who was like
highly placed in the world of
immunobiology you know the course is
called immunobiology not immunology
immunobiology it had the right focus and
as i recall it
the professor stood sideways to the
chalkboard staring off into space
literally stroking his beard with this
bemused look on his face through the
entire lecture
and you know you had all these medical
students who were so furiously writing
notes that i don't even think they were
noticing the person delivering this
thing but
you know i got what this guy was smiling
about it was like so
what he was describing you know adaptive
immunity is so marvelous
right that it was like almost a
privilege to even be saying it to a room
full of people who were listening you
know
but anyway yeah i took that course and
you know lo and behold
that's coveted useful well yeah suddenly
it's
front and center and wow am i glad i
took it but um
anyway yeah useless courses are great
and actually eric
gave me one of the greater pieces of
advice at least for college than
anyone's ever given
which was don't worry about the prereqs
take it anyway
right but now i don't even know if kids
can do this now because the prereqs are
now enforced by a computer
but back in the day if you didn't
mention that you didn't have the prereqs
nobody stopped you from taking the
course and what he told me which i
didn't know was
that often the advanced courses are
easier in some way
the material is complex but you know you
know
it's not like intro bio where you're
learning a thousand things at once
right it's like focused on something so
if you dedicate yourself you can you can
pull it off
yeah stay with an idea for many weeks at
a time and it's ultimately rewarding
and not as difficult as it looks yeah
you